this is an eight news now breaking news
alert
he was
the sweetest soul he always smiled
and played and he was rambunctious and
spunky
hurt
shocking
i just don't see how you could do this
to your own child
another tragic day as the body of little
amari nicholson is discovered not far
from where he was first reported missing
this as the accused killer appears
before a judge
good evening and thank you for joining
us here at five the search for the body
of two-year-old amari has come to an end
and the push for his justice is
beginning thanks for joining us i'm
denise feltes and i'm brian loftis we
have team coverage joe mohler is live
where a memorial and vigil plan for
tonight the i-team's vanessa murphy
first broke the story of terrell rhodes
alleged confession and arrest but we
begin with victoria saha live from the
area where amari was found earlier this
afternoon
brian i'm at segal suites where amari
was found just after one o'clock this
afternoon there was a huge police
presence and this is right next to
emerald suites the last known location
of omari after an extensive search for
amari he was found behind this wall
crowds gathered when the news broke
about amari's body being discovered
strangers watched amari was as he was
placed into a funeral home car yelling
we love you amari there were so many
emotions today coming from people who
have been following this case for a week
and themselves have gone and searched
for any clues that may have led them to
amari i spoke to a woman here who lives
close by she tells me she was handing
out flyers this week and as devastating
of an end this is she's glad amari was
finally found
my heart is broken for this baby and his
family
we've been i've been helping pass out
flyers
and
we've walked and looked we've checked
our trash cans
we've looked everywhere it's too close
to home
as the scene cleared off at the seagull
sweets amari's mom taylor nicholson
showed up at the mcdonald's next door
and it appeared police were talking to
her the crowd gathered there and was
very emotional but she did not appear to
be crying or in shock and then drove off
now i was out here on saturday as
volunteers handed out flyers of course
they're all very upset they couldn't
find amari earlier reporting live from
segal suites victoria saha 8 news now
victoria thank you memorial continues to
grow outside of emerald sweets all day
long people leaving those messages for a
life lost far too soon that's where joe
moeller now joins us live joe
yeah that vigil will take place here in
about an hour's time we're hearing that
amari's father is expected to be here
now the memorial has been growing
throughout the day we've been watching
people drop off balloons candles uh
stuffed animals people have been writing
on this post right here rest in peace
amari and uh you are getting justice now
this is outside the emerald suites and
they give you an idea of how close this
was uh to the seagull suites where his
body was found you can see that brown
building right there so this is just
yards away from that location now there
was a number of people outside there
earlier today when this all unfolded
including juana salazar who was helping
search for amari
we went there last night and we we put
some candles down and we put teddy bears
the football down and a sign down we'll
be back here tonight there's relief
because he's he's
he's gonna rest he's going to he's going
to be laid to rest now
after the arrest of 27 year old terrell
rhodes that is amari's mom mom's
boyfriend that is i was in contact with
amari's father's family they had asked
for privacy however a representative
from nevada child seekers who was
helping with this search was with them
last night and said they were very
shocked to hear about the arrest that
was made in connection with this now
there is a vigil set here where this
memorial continues to grow it'll be
happening at six o'clock they are
expecting a big presence reporting live
here near twain in paradise joe muller 8
news now
well as joe mentioned there terrell
rhodes was arrested and is now charged
with first-degree murder continue our
coverage here at five the i-team's
vanessa murphy and vanessa there were
concerns about his safety even his
grandmother alluded to it leading up to
his death
that's right denise we've learned there
may have been warning signs that amari
nicholson was in danger sources tell me
within the past year there was at least
one report made to child protective
services alleging abuse and the agency
looked into the allegation but closed
the case without taking further action i
reached out to cps but a spokesman says
state law prohibits them from discussing
specific individuals as we first
reported now terrell rhodes is in jail
accused of killing the child
do you think if cps had
investigated more after these calls
you're saying the family made do you
think omari would be safe right now
yes ma'am
he'd be just fine carrie howard is amari
nicholson's maternal grandmother on
monday she told the i-team loved ones
had been concerned about the safety of
the two-year-old child since his mother
started dating terrell rhodes last year
on tuesday sources told the eye team
rhodes confessed to killing amari
[Music]
are you mr rhodes the 27 year old man
appeared in court for a murder charge
wednesday we would note that the
defendant lied for approximately one
week
regarding
covering up the murder that we were made
against
on may 7th amari's mother taylor
nicholson and rhodes talked with eight
news now's joe moeller rhodes was
watching amari while his mom was out of
town he claimed a woman calling herself
an aunt showed up to take the child and
as i'm
going to call my girlfriend and pack his
bag at the same time she says that they
already got everything that they need
for him then she
proceeded out the door but metro police
say rhodes later admitted to hitting
omaree numerous times which caused his
death on may 5th two days before that
interview and then hid the child's body
according to the clark county district
attorney's office evidence includes
blood on a wall and soiled child's
clothing detectives say they knew rhodes
was their primary suspect while rhodes
continued to give his version to eight
news now what's really sickening is that
people is
making assumptions thinking that i have
something to do with it that i have
heard
manipulated in some way
which
that sticking into me also because
if you love us we
never do nothing like that
police say rhodes fought with officers
and grabbed an officer's gun when they
went to arrest him he will likely face
charges in connection with that incident
the i-team has learned rhodes was
released from prison last year for
robbery and burglary convictions brian
back to you okay vanessa thank you for
your reporting on this